pg emi music store islamica vale oggi
facciamo un challenge inventate noi
abbiamo preparato scatterà allora
praticamente questo challenge e non
scegliere il buco sbagliato o il
dipartimento sbagliando dalle ceneri di
un corner 8 comportamento o il numero
sbagliato praticamente una volta
metteremo nel uno dei due e 3 3 cose di
cui due brutte schifose e luna sarà una
sorpresa ha sempre cibo ma non si fosse
prestito ha dato modo tutto alla fine
del video chi avrà fatto più punti
quindi chi avrà collezionato più
sorprese potrà aprire frutte questo
prete e le nostre sorprese sono i nuovi
consoli delle coccole d'ore nuovi
cuccioli delle coccole potete trovarli
in edicola questa è la scatola dei
cuccioli delle coccole
per una bustina enorme trova la cuccia
per il tuo cucciolo perché ogni bustina
contiene una cuccia che si può montare
poi andiamo a vedere la siamo in base a
chi capiterà la prima sorpresa poi
contiene fu solo un accessorio è un
fascicolo
ecco qua la bustino 13 cuccia i 12
cuccioli da a collezionare come di
siccome noi adoriamo i cuccioli i
cagnolini facciamo troppo contenetevi
aprile in questo sorpresa in più sul
sito lion giocattoli puntoit scritto
lyon giocato il punto it potete
scaricare stampare la mappa però tutte
le cucce tra le prime cose sorpresa se
chi farà più punti quindi a chi che ne
capiteranno di più potrà offrire sul
resto del pallone i nuovi cuccioli delle
coccole che comunque abbiamo l'ora di
vedere assieme siamo pronti analisi del
video dovrete dirsi pone il su ciò che
mi è piaciuto più crede alle 10 si sono
giunti gaga appunto bello aspettare ha
lasciato un bel ex se volete vedere
attrezzare gli spazi espositivi cosi
prendete i bancari caso la vita le
iniziali bello di tutti belli e io vado
a mettere le tre cose tratta band
ma faccia piatto non è sorpreso e
bloccato da un soggetto che sono pronto
a posizionare le cose sembrano tizi
orari cantare una canzone se lo senti il
rumore allora tappati le orecchie e
canta o vorrebbero nostro è allora la
ragazza che klose
[Musica]
basta e morselli ok ho fatto adesso no
ti toglierà band ha incoronato devi dire
che il numero 6 e poi qui togliere la
benda che forse gli porto paura due o
tre filari la mano nel 2 non vedo più
niente fino in fondo è ancora non ci sei
ancora non ci sei più geloso grigio e
rosa mi mostri da un braccio mi hanno
costretta
da un proprio tipo prenderla si vede mai
hai sentito dispiace per te ma la
sorpresa
adesso dove sarà la cittadina quindi se
come the universe po sorpreso la posto
periodo al prossimo tocca a me ma se io
perdo tu potrai aprire la sorpresa
quindi andiamo innanzitutto la prima
mostrato il primo offrono mio primo
sorpreso dalle file dei cuccioli che
diamo un pò come allora che razza di
questo cane san bernardo bellissimo che
ha una ferita qua ma c'è anche qualcosa
per curarlo vediamo allora quali sono
gli adesivi permettergli 00 glory
t magazine con vari informazioni sui
cuccioli troviamo la puzzetta da montare
allora vediamo un pochissimo possa
aprirla qua
praticamente si monta da sola da settori
che carino da pezzetto ferrozzi che
carino pensa che ruba cibo roma eccolo
qua la mettiamo dentro la cuccetta poi
vediamo cosa abruzzo è qua dentro allora
c'è sempre una sorpresa in più è più tra
è in questo caso è un puzzle di spider
man qua e là composto ma ovviamente si
può togliere il tutto messo fuori
comporterebbe un foglio di labyring in a
per curare il cagnolino cacciare o mini
cerotto va da un mezzo chilo sulla
ferita nella zampa guardate un po orano
fiego età da un cerottino nella ferita
nella zampa che carino con l'arrivo di
fuori che mi vendo e lo farà la brava e
cantano le canzoni non come evitare che
carta notte
tutte cose competeva ecco qua
[Musica]
mai
sì decisa perché le due è il mio numero
preferito mar rosso l'uno e verso quindi
ho paura che l'uno mi porterà sfortuna
perché è verde ok estremisti perché in
rosa no il 30 lo utilizzarlo per due
rosa 3 chiedo il 3 va bene ok smettere
vado a infilare la mano ha detto a
guardare aiuto
speriamo bene speriamo per promuover
oddio che cos'è
ma non so niente jolly veloce fortunata
ragionano avremo riesco a prenderla una
crediamo che questo lo abbiamo allora
vediamo la puzzetta prima questa volta è
compatto la puzzetta è montata me vi
diamo subito il nostro cucciolo carino
guardate che richiederà o di carini vivo
sono sorta di biberon
eccolo qua ho sempre gli adesivi con
cerottini e bandane c'è sempre la
sorpresa in più vediamo questa volta è
un partner bebè di spiderman però
l'immagine è diverso
[Musica]
ok ho fatto che numerose di 123 allora
vediamo e devo pensare alle stelle un
loro secondo me la sorpresa di una
sorpresa è stata messa prima che anche
numero stata sorpresa non te lo dica
allora 101 ma infila la mano questo caso
non è lo stupratore ci credi ti faccio
un altro punto aggiunto anche sospeso
per me che era del numero due
almeno però che cosa carina che non
posso mandare si possono mangiare il
compito di cui ce lo troveremo qua e
compatto dove rate che carina e finiva
in esso funziona
ognuna bellino borsa colle che carino
finora questo è il mio preferito agli
occhioni azzurri del tutto accucciato
così glielo asperità qual è la cosa ma
si può mettere appunto il 0 0 che carino
e in questo caso la storia era il
biberon verde e possiamo metterli il
giro ci mettiamo gli its e rottino rossa
che carino si unisce presto il nuovo
bellissimo questo cucciolo ne vediamo
qual è il nostro extra festa molto il
passo delle principesse disney che belle
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ha detto basta abitiamo
si ok allora quale c'è il gene è
un'altra
allora primo senso stretto è venuta
dentro prima ci ha detto che non ha
funzionato dei 23 quindi forse pensare
che non aumenti nelle sue così sa chi e
circoli tu o che non c'è coltura della
tua risposta definitiva vai dove i due
club per quello andiamo a prendere la
mia sorpresa
oddio che cos'è il peso di visita e una
sana è certo
va bene però vinto questa volta no
questo significa che ho visto io a 31 il
numero uno verde perché ho detto che
l'intervento mettiamo la sorpresa 12
ferroso che temo il verde che hanno di
certo rosea per i cervi attiva
l'altro non anni e l'altra donna anni
che anche lui ha ferito qui sul petto la
richiesta per curarlo e zero ei cerotti
come al solito si adesso li mettiamo una
bella banda quando fasciatura qui sul
petto così albero guarisce presto
facciamo tutto il petto ecco qua
mettiamo subito vedere con l'extra di
questo fatto più punti questo primo
anche gli altri ma ne regalo alcuni
anche avvitare ice mi dispiace che ha
fatto solo un punto quindi tieni in
questa pubblico grazie a me è capitato
un spazzole deve scoverete che carino
che magari lo si faccia
il rom orecchio si vede c'è un basso
tiro barbato barboncino però è diverso
tutto bianco sono ferito ma dietro e il
biberon e attendete riuscito un golden
retriever che la bambina molato ma
potete qui il cucciolo abbiamo qua un
beagle con il v verona ragione ora che
li facciamo vedere tutti e potrete dirci
qual è il vostro con solo per facebook
ho qua tutti bellissimi cuccioli
guardate che carini allora curateli bene
perchè dovete scrivere qual è il vostro
preferito sono tutti carinissimi eccoli
qua allora il mio preferito è questo qui
che dovrebbe essere il border collie mon
cordate che carino con costruzioni
azzurri è bellissimo invece qual è il
tuo preferito
il mio preferito invece il pastore
tedesco che carino bellissimo ma sono
tutti carinissimi troppo troppo ben
meraviglie sono felicissimo di persone
di tutti
fateci sapere qual è il vostro preferito
lasciato un bel se volete un'altra
challenge con la scatola iii sezione che
sono regalati dai tacchi o qualcuno